- It's taking all of my strength
not to just play with it right now.
(laughs)
(light music)
- I bought my coworker a toy.
Is that weird?
I bought a toy for you.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Do I actually get to
keep it after this video?
- That's up to Buzzfeed
and not
I can't comment on that so--
- Alright.
- (laughs) It's already making sounds.
First thing I do.
- You're going to break it.
- This is how you check presents.
- Okay.
- You got to know if it's Legos or not.
It's a Star Wars something.
- It's a Star Wars Perplexus Death Star.
- Is this like in the new
movie and I don't know it yet?
- I should have gotten the scissors.
- Yeah, you should have
gotten the scissors.
This is going to be impossible to open.
Come on.
Just get the toy out.
(laughing)
- Twist, spin and use Rebel
Alliance squadron tactics
to maneuver the ball
through the challenging maze mission.
- Oh, so there's a little X-Wing in here
that seems to be on a thing
and it's going to fly around
and I need to--
- I guess so.
- Almost broke my toy.
So it's attached by a magnet
and as you can see right here,
I'm about to knock it off
of its X-Wing magnet thing.
You see that?
So now what do you do?
It's like a big hamster ball, really.
- They just took a hamster ball
and put some (bleep) in it.
(bleep) This has no instructions.
Ooh, there's a ball in there.
- Where?
- In there.
- No, that's a screw.
- Oh, that's a screw.
- So I think we're missing a huge part
of this toy.
I think we turn this upside down.
Nope, that does nothing.
- So we kind of figured
it out a little bit.
- Alright.
- There's a starting point.
- Get it in the top and
then it kind of like
spirals down a little bit.
- And then it goes in there.
- Goes in there.
- Okay.
- [Both] Whoa.
- Yeah.
- He did it.
It got more fun now
that we figured it out.
- [Both] Oh.
- Okay, this game is awesome.
- It has little arrows to help you.
- So now it's in that cup.
- Is it in the cup?
- You just have to turn it
upside down really quickly.
- Oh, you did it.
- Maybe we should redo our--
- Oh God.
- Our rankings.
Beauty.
- Beauty.
This is a good shelf toy.
This is going to look good on your shelf.
You're going to want to play with it.
It looks good next to
other Star Wars stuff
but it's a little different.
- Fun level.
Shut up.
Wait let's turn it off.
- Fun level.
It depends on the kind of
person you are honestly.
I had a lot of fun once I figured it out.
- I think it's fun because
it isn't impossible but it is challenging.
Perplexus.
- Perplexus.
- It's called Perplexus.
- They perplexed us
by not providing any instructions.
I got to fault them at that a little bit.
(light music)